[Música]
en el marco del foro por la paz de París
representantes del gobierno de Nicolás
maduro y de la oposición de Venezuela
tuvieron un primer encuentro que marca
un reinicio de diálogos entre las partes
las conversaciones que continuarán en
México cuentan con el impulso dado por
Francia Colombia y Argentina
el congreso peruano citó al presidente
Pedro Castillo para que se defienda
luego de que la subcomisión de
acusaciones constitucionales aprobará el
informe que indica que el mandatario
Debería ser inhabilitado por cinco años
por presunta traición a la patria ese
día el pleno del legislativo votar a la
moción
datos oficiales revelan una cifra récord
de deforestación en la amazonía
brasileña en octubre de 2022 un 3%
superior al mismo mes del año pasado los
31 días de octubre de este año 9004
kilómetros fueron deforestados según el
sistema de vigilancia satelital
en francés 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornadas soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en París la
capital francesa porque en el marco del
foro por la paz se produjo el reinicio
de las conversaciones entre el chavismo
y la oposición venezolana se trata del
primer encuentro a Puerta cerrada entre
las partes después de un año de
suspensión un diálogo impulsado por el
presidente francés Emmanuel maccom
anfitrión del foro las conversaciones
también cuentan con el respaldo del
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro y
de Argentina Alberto Fernández Esta
primera reunión sirve como nuevo impulso
de diálogo entre el gobierno y la
oposición unas conversaciones que
continuarán en México considerado
territorio neutral para negociar damos
un repaso por los intentos fallidos de
negociación entre el gobierno y la
oposición en el informe de Manuela Cano
la crisis política en Venezuela no es
nueva ni tampoco lo son los intentos de
conversaciones entre el gobierno y la
oposición en medio de pedidos de
destitución del presidente Nicolás
maduro y una atención política ambas
partes se reunían en Caracas en 2016
unas negociaciones acompañadas por el
Vaticano España Panamá y República
Dominicana Entonces el gobierno se
mostraba optimista queremos hacer
nuestras palabras de saludo del
presidente Y comprometernos de forma
profunda a que este diálogo tenga
resultados certeros y rápidos pero los
intentos de una salida dialogada se
desvanecieron rápidamente ambos bandos
lo intentaron de nuevo en República
Dominicana La entonces jefa de la
asamblea constitucional recalcaba la
relevancia del diálogo en 2017 la única
vía para Venezuela es el diálogo es la
paz no hay otra vía no podemos permitir
que las órdenes imperiales que los
poderes fácticos se impongan una agenda
de violencia en el suelo una agenda de
guerra pero las partes fallaron en
encontrar una fecha para unas elecciones
presidenciales y los diálogos entraron
en un receso indefinido las
conversaciones se reanudaron en Barbados
en 2019 pero maduro decidió levantarse
de la mesa por el apoyo de la oposición
a las sanciones económicas impuestas a
Venezuela por parte de Estados Unidos
Ciudad de México habría una nueva
esperanza de llegar a una salida a la
crisis política Venezuela está mal está
muy mal
nuestro pueblo sufre la peor crisis de
su historia contemporánea
agradecimiento y aunque las partes
lograron llegar a una serie de acuerdos
las conversaciones fracasaron luego del
pedido de los representantes del
gobierno te incorporar al diálogo al
empresario Colombo venezolano alexaap
había sido pedido una extradición por
parte de Estados Unidos que lo acusaba
de lavado de activos el congreso peruano
citó al presidente Pedro Castillo el
próximo miércoles 16 de noviembre para
que se defienda de las acusaciones de
traición a la patria contenidos en un
informe que aprobó la subcomisión de
asuntos constitucionales el texto
recomienda la inhabilitación de Castillo
para ejercer cargos públicos por 5 años
Lo que implica que tendría que dejar la
presidencia la subcomisión Consideró que
el mandatario cometió un delito al decir
que consultaría al pueblo sobre la
posibilidad de darle una salida al mar a
Bolivia una afirmación que hizo en una
entrevista dada a la cadena CNN en
español
no nos amilan a nosotros acá estamos por
el país porque antes que todo está el
ciudadano les decía y espero de que el
congreso de la República
actúe de Mirando al pueblo peruano en
Centroamérica los repetidos fenómenos
meteorológicos extremos impactan
gravemente el sector de la agricultura
hace unas semanas la tormenta Julia
causó la muerte de más de 50 personas y
destruyó miles de hectáreas en cultivos
en Nicaragua El Salvador Guatemala y
Honduras la hija de él nos cuenta más
un mes después del paso de la tormenta
Julián Las cicatrices aún son visibles
en Honduras en este campo Las lluvias
arrastraron todos sus cultivos y la
tierra sigue cubierta de agua fangosa
ahorita estuvieramos ya ya preparando ya
preparar la tierra para sembrar de nuevo
pero como se vino está llena ya no
sembramos sino que vamos a esperar a que
seque en El Salvador estos agricultores
tampoco pueden cosechar maíz un alimento
esencial para sostener a sus familias
esperan la llegada de ayudas de parte de
las instituciones para sobrevivir antes
de poder retomar la producción
desde lo único que nosotros vivimos Y si
por decirlo así si el gobierno o alguna
instituciones no nos apoyan nos vamos a
ver más afectados no más allá Pues
porque ahorita no tenemos que darle el
ganado ni ni que comer pues los
agricultores guatemaltecos comparten la
misma angustia el Ministerio de
agricultura contabilizó 60.000 tareas de
cultivos afectados en diferentes niveles
por la tormenta tropical Julia estamos
bien asustados porque no hay donde nos
vamos a ir porque ya no tenemos terreno
para comprar no tenemos pisto para
comprar un pedacito en tan siquiera un
sitio las crisis me dio ambientales
están en el centro de las preocupaciones
de organismos e instituciones un informe
del Banco Mundial alerta que los
impactos del cambio climático podrían
empujar a 132 millones de personas a la
pobreza en los próximos 10 años
continuando con temas ambientales
durante octubre de 2022 se registró la
tala de otros 9004 kilómetros cuadrados
en la amazonía brasileña lo que
representa un 3% más de área perdida que
el mismo mes del año pasado la alarmante
cifra récord fue revelada por el sistema
de vigilancia satelital del Instituto
Nacional de investigaciones espaciales
los datos señalan además que la
deforestación acumulada entre el primero
de enero y el 31 de octubre de este año
es de
9.494 kilómetros cuadrados a su vez la
filial en Brasil de la ong fondo mundial
para la naturaleza alertó que tras las
elecciones presidenciales el número de
incendios se disparó
y en el marco de la cop 27 Franz 24 les
ofrece una serie de reportajes
especiales relacionados con la crisis
climática en esta oportunidad vamos a
Ecuador donde el retroceso del 50% de
los glaciares volcánicos es una de las
consecuencias más evidentes del
calentamiento global el informe es de
Gustavo Ortega corresponsal en Quito
Luisa Machado centinela en el parque
nacional antisana su tarea de proteger
el volcán es cada vez más ardua el
deshielo avanza cada año y atenta con
dejar sin agua a la población que habita
en la capital ecuatoriana el retroceso
es de 20 a 25 metros por año y eso es
realmente preocupante es una cantidad de
retroceso muy muy pronunciada que que a
la vez afecta tanto a la producción de
agua Además del deshielo el agua que se
consume en la capital ecuatoriana
proviene de esta laguna de origen
glaciar a 35 kilómetros del volcán
antisana la que la escasez de lluvias
amenazan estos reservorios naturales
reduciendo sus niveles de agua
la sequía también preocupa Patricio
Muñoz guardaparques quien conoce el
lugar desde hace 40 años para proteger
la diversidad vegetal siembra huertos
que aspira convertir en 5000 nuevas
plantas al año la vegetación muere
constantemente por la falta de lluvias y
el incremento del sol se contabilizaban
hasta
300 días de lluvia no y apenas teníamos
un mes
entre medio seco o medio húmedo hoy
totalmente ha cambiado
me agrada que la zona de amortiguamiento
aún la tenemos además de la flora
también la fauna está sufriendo de los
estragos de los cambios de temperatura
ante la migración de muchas especies
Luisa vigila que el cóndor ave típica
nacional en peligro de extinción
permanezca en su hábitat natural
camino al antisana el desgaste glaciar
devela sus capas rocosas a kilómetros de
distancia y confirma nuevas amenazas las
microplásticos Y eso también es un
factor que durante años ya sea por
actividades turísticas por actividades
antrópicas y el mismo ambiente ya tiene
microplásticos y están depositados en el
Nevado in total son 120.000 hectáreas
diarias protegidas amenazadas de
desaparecer este parque natural
poblaciones enteras quedarían sin agua y
ya no existiría el ecosistema más rico
de Ecuador así llegamos al final de esta
informativo a ustedes Les agradecemos su
sintonía continúen con nosotros que
volvemos en breve
[Música]